[Musique]
tu sais comment marche la maison on
expliqué et si les règles sont durs ces
strictes
le père françois nous a dit que tu avais
fait une overdose
t'inquiète pas insulter jusqu'ici on a
tous connu la même chose il y aura rien
porter
pas de médicaments pas d'alcool pas des
cigarettes
[Musique]
pas des fines en plus elles vivent
ailleurs dans une autre maison tout en
énergie doit être consacrée à la prière
au travail tu seras jamais seule il y
aura une version avec toi on l'appelle
l'ange gardien peut te confier la mer
[Musique]
tu sais que c'est difficile pour toi tu
obtiens siècle et phrases
[Musique]
salut tu étais là où chez les tox les
anciens tox prague et si j'étais toi je
retournerai là haut je me colle une
balle si je retourne
c'est la seule chance de s'en sortir
[Musique]
m
est devenu croyons
[Musique]
essai réussi fans du show jeudi au père
du coup j'ai eu plus de sentiments
possibles
ce fonds
dire que t'es pas encore prêt
[Musique]
des triches vocation
si tu vis dans le mensonge que peut pas
être heureux
[Musique]